pis tiers commence avant ça va bien
merci très bien alors j'imagine qu'à
plein de raisons se résout il ya le
succès du film de guillaume canet finir
ensemble et tout ce que nicolas bedos
est tous très bien et survoler le
connaissez très bien nicolas bedos il
vous a parlé d'agression suffit parce
qu'il faisait très chaud
l'actrice porte surprise
je dois lui seul est déjà ville
maintenant terminé et j'ai tellement
riche pour lui d'être là qu'il soit là
ce soir car le meilleur
c'est magnifique et le film et je
cherche tellement relégation
avec son public voilà amoureux du cinéma
c'est
vous définirez ça passe le panicaut là
bas j'ai adoré son premier film à l'art
avec un grand succès c'est quelqu'un qui
fait du grand cinéma comme
l'accord n'a plus beaucoup en france en
fait alors il ya des ya une diversité
magnifique en france les 5 et
merveilleux mais ce souffle qui
reviennent au cinéma princesse et c'est
quelque chose de très très bons jeux
merci beaucoup
[Musique]